[Musique]
qui es-tu à qui je trouve la réponse
à laquelle je ne porterais pas de masque
là-bas les gens croient que ce monde est
juste et que ce
ne sont que des sucettes et des arcs-en-ciel
nous ne faisons pas de sucettes et d'arcs-en-ciel nous
savons qu'ils sont jolis  des couleurs telles que
cacher ce que le monde est vraiment en noir et
blanc bientôt je crierai sauvez-nous et
nous chuchoterons
nous nous convaincrons qu'ils étaient
partis mais ils hibernaient juste
ils sont venus une nuit fabuleuse
oh s'il vous plaît
des attaques simultanées coordonnées aux
maisons de Tulsa [ __ ] jusqu'à  les flics cachent
leur visage et maintenant les méchants ne
savent pas où ils habitent et qui ne veulent pas d'
identité secrète les gens qui portent des
masques sont dangereux nous devrions avoir peur
d'eux car cela cache quelque chose
Laurie Blake FBI vous savez comment vous pouvez
faire la différence entre un flic masqué
et un justicier non moi non plus
il y a un complot vaste et insidieux
je joue contre vous un pirate non encore
expulsera
qui êtes-vous peut-être ouais je suis dr.  Menon il
vit sur [ __ ] de Mars tu maudits trop